[Music]
in 1776
a powerful empire was born in north
america
the lakotas had reached the black hills
the most sacred place and most coveted
buffalo hunting grounds in the western
plains
located in what is now south dakota
control of the black hills or pahasapa
marked the lakotas as the dominant power
in the american west just a few decades
before they were vying for power in the
eastern woodlands and losing
one of seven nations or seven council
fires that made up the sioux alliance
the lakotas had lived in the forests and
wetlands between the great lakes and the
missouri valley for centuries
in the 1600s european colonizers
destabilized this region while some
tribes profited by trading furs with new
france the lakotas lived just out of
range of the best trade opportunities so
in the early 1700s they turned their
attention west
the western plains were much less
fertile and abundant than the lakota's
homelands the only easy access to food
and water was immediately alongside the
rivers
land arikaras had already claimed to
compete the lakotas became skilled
buffalo hunters and warriors on
horseback
they conquered the farming archers
forcing them to pay tributes of maize
and squash
when the spanish arrived expecting to
find lucrative trading grounds they had
to pay tolls to the lakotas instead
in 1804 a new spectacle came floating up
the missouri river meriwether lewis and
william clark
lakota chief black buffalo refused to
let them pass until they paid a hefty
tribute
in spite of this rocky start the
expedition marked the beginning of a
close trade alliance between the lakotas
and the united states
lakota men hunted buffalo while women
processed the hides into robes for trade
the u.s government supplied guns
ammunition and other goods even
providing lakotas with smallpox vaccines
that protected them from the deadly
epidemics that ravaged other native
american nations
on paper the united states had acquired
the lakota's lands from france and the
louisiana purchase
but the lakotas would not cede their
lands because of an agreement between
two foreign powers though there were 15
000 lakotas and 23 million americans the
bulk of u.s population and military
might was concentrated on the east coast
just getting an army to lakota territory
presented a huge expense and once there
they would face formidable warriors with
deep local knowledge and alliances to
avoid a war it couldn't afford and
wouldn't win the u.s government
attempted to appease the lakotas paying
steep tributes of ammunition and rations
demanded by lakota leaders
so while almost all the native americans
in north america were being forced off
their lands and onto reservations the
lakota empire was still expanding
by 1850 they controlled some 500 000
square kilometers they were spread
thinly across this vast area moving
their villages in pursuit of buffalo
though there was no central authority
the leaders of bands or oyates came
together at annual sundances to
strategize and coordinate complex
diplomatic operations lasting a few
weeks each summer sundances were
spiritual ceremonies that reaffirmed
communal ties appeased wakan tanka the
great spirit and kept the world in
balance starting in 1849 the california
gold rush brought hordes of white
settlers west encroaching on lakota
territory
and disturbing the buffalo herds lakota
leaders correctly interpreted this
migration as a signal that the u.s no
longer intended to respect their claim
to the land in retaliation they attacked
wagon trains and government offices
as the conflict grew chief red cloud
negotiated in washington dc while back
in lakota territory chiefs sitting bull
crazy horse and others prepared for
battle they mobilized their cheyenne and
arapaho allies and almost all the other
sioux nations against the us
in 1876 exactly 100 years after the
lakota's arrival
gold prospectors occupied the sacred
black hills from many lakotas this was
the final straw following a vision by
sitting bull
crazy horse led lakota forces to
decisively defeat the americans in the
battle of the little bighorn
after this victory the lakotas faced an
even graver threat wagon travel and
railroad construction had decimated
buffalo populations and they faced
starvation
to survive they moved onto reservations
where u.s officials murdered sitting
bull and crazy horse and attempted to
dismantle their culture prohibiting the
sundance on reservations
the lakotas started a protest movement
called the ghost dance
alarmed by this resistance in 1890 the
u.s army massacred hundreds of lakotas
many of them women and children at
wounded knee creek
today lakotas continue to fight for
their culture and their land
in 2016 they drew supporters worldwide
to protest construction of the dakota
access pipeline through their
reservation
continuing a long history of resistance
to a government known for breaking its
promises
travel to the southern plains of the
united states with this video and learn
about the comanches
another horse-mounted tribe who fought
to keep their land and sovereignty as
settlers pushed west into their
territory